thor 2 si vous aviez un ticket michaël
youn se serait keep scarlett johansson
comme ça je suis sûr que ça arrivera
jamais tu sur ses pairs vargas carladous
du kung fu tu confonds avec scarlett à
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
scarlett abitbol d'algérie il adore et
qui joue à kin phoenix non non tu
connais joie joaquim phoenix et ont des
déchets k-way il va il va à mon avis va
voir le il va avoir l'oscar ans après le
caire
ça va pas il ya une possibilité à lui
arranger ça puis le nouveau no lo diana
rigg jusqu'en chapeau melon en 1960 a
pas quelqu'un de l'art de vivre à ce que
diana rigg faire il ya que lui qui peut
être la chercher sous terre tu vas pas
me dire michael jackson aussi moqué jean
démord pas mais quoi tiennent à rien
dans leur formule on vient vous j'hésite
que c'est un pas mal banamba plaisir dit
tout le monde alors j'hésite entre jason
statham non si j'aime bien je te dise le
pommeau jason statham c'est très gros
j'aime bien cette entame tulle a changé
un russell crowe sean cronin guelleh a
reçu un confrère il a passé deux mois
chez maromme id com
ce que tu dis ça c'est au sol c'est
russell a les crocs matin sur la vie de
ma mère mon père à temps george clooney
parce que bon il y avait jose souligne
alain petit bail au pénal mais j'aurais
aimé vous le savez les deux là s'il vous
plaît pas parler de la bastille au pays
c'est pas parce qu'on est petit qu'on
peut tout se permettre
[Rires]
ah ouais bah oui d'accord mais je sais
mais ça non c'est pas possible
elle est quand même souvent en france
l'epita g du bagout non mais oui on joue
pas pour moi j'ai 58 ans elle aussi mais
c'est vrai qu'elle est magnifique
rebelles et je suis d'accord et c'est
pas possible ça tel est en tout cas
c'est ce dont je crois le plus lu à
quelqu'un de mort lui bon scarlett
johansson dieu parce que je peux faire
vous je vais voir aussi elle sait pas
elle tout le monde mais naïve à la fin
de chaque sous call home agl encore tout
voir
[Rires]
écoutez cette équipe
non non c'est une blague cette semaine
stammen non non non c'était avec qui il
est et nathalie tommasini et ses frères
excuse moi j'aime beaucoup cette
personne je ne sais pas qui c'est mais
si vous la connaissez c'est qui me plaît
pas reçu sur le plateau
mais non elle fait quoi mais si elle est
avocate elle a défendu jacqueline
sauvage d'ailleurs un an avant il défend
la cause l'égalité hommes-femmes et une
belle paire ce pourquoi les rossfeldois
belle balade sans doute qu'elle a envie
que tu l'as si tu m'écoutes ou alors
c'est moi alors moi si j'avais un tic
acier and wallace un ticket je dirais
shy'm shy'm et ouais et alors
alors
ouais
est-ce que je peux changer scarlett
johansson pour shy'm allez je te
bifurqua merci à toi comme tu es mieux
faut que tu l'appelles chine elle dégage
un truc très sensuelle le serveur était
déjà un peu il paraît que tu aimes bien
mettre au gym également et on a les
mêmes goûts avec chanel même jour quoi
série avec mais pas de la même année là
deux cents d'écart alors s'il vous plaît
surpris de ce calme et où c'est quoi
jeter chaque allée brimeux te rappelles
1 ce que j'ai fait pour toi j'te dis
fabien un oui c'est vrai tu m'a présenté
mon essai un peu
j'imagine avec shine
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui alors vous avancez serait leonardo
dicaprio
je sais pas moi si tu peux ouais mais
c'était dans le monde oui moi c'est un
deuxième ouais ouais j'en ai un deuxième
parce que dans ce film là il est docteur
il est vrai la sûreté jimmy mohamed
c'est un peu c'est un peu l'inversé
ramzy rises et attrape moi quand tu veux
on va en parler de radi dans un instant
oui vous sharon stone et monica bellucci
ouais à laquelle les noms par les veuves
par leur prénom tout est tranquille
oui monica bellucci statut la rencontre
ap
we will et les deux d'ailleurs mais mais
en plus et alain herard un chat charles
9eme pas cher on se tue pourrait-on son
style à les belges aiment beaucoup parce
que d'abord elle est très marrante les
livres il à la fois elle m'a dit j'adore
les mecs qui font des yeux elle est
géniale cette femme ah ouais vous prônez
francs 4 alors d'environ 15 à aider de
même que celui qui m'amuse le pétillant
sardou michel sardou dans les rockets
[Applaudissements]
michel sardou michel zaoui selah sue 600
personnalités parfois bizarres et me
fait rire celle en a rien à [ __ ] et
ouais tu pourrais avoir donc si tu as un
ticket toi tu appelles michel sardou ah
non mais moi ce n'est pas du tout envie
de faire l'amour la nasa se sont dits
oui mais j'adore croix qui est votre
journal a envie d'aller au resto en fait
oui mais alors juste manger à l'oeil
tu crois pas tu as menée sur les lacs du
connemara je pense qu'il va rien me
faire franchement je n'attire pas du
tout mais en revanche on pourrait faire
l'humour ensemble merci mois sophie
marceau allez sortez que cyril lignac
je partais pas cuisiner mettre un petit
monde se retrouve à ta femme
oui absolument ça fait longtemps que
j'ai pas la même veste
[Rires]
oui c'est pas du tout même si le désert
c'est un peu vrai mais le style pierre
mois sur cette faute a dit à des
problèmes avec les fans de tes
chroniques et je les adore non mais t'as
du mal à imprimer
je suis très ami avec cauet et je peux
te dire je la vois plus souvent plus
jeunes
alors moi si j'étais pas très amoureux
je prendrais ou sean penn bradley cooper
ou daniel craig mais comme je suis très
amoureuse mon ticket je le prendrais
pour une femme et je proposerai à crédit
un bout de chemin avec moi alors alors
moi je peux peut-être filmé la séquence
je sais pas quel jour bah tu nous diras
talent sur le terrain dit ouf voilà
merci à eux
vous moi c'est en été si je dois faire
une connerie c'est audrey fleurot
messieurs on connaît ça dormir
audrey fleurot squat à son numéro direct
on l'appelle direct paris andré de
fleury appel
audrey fleurot répond ah ouais vas-y
dans les michaël youn ou réponse dit je
vais avoir un rôle tout sa femme y en
avait mais ça y est elle a eu dans la
merde
s'il vous plaît maintenant on n'a pas le
des gens connus là s'il vous plaît en
appel des gens connus là elle est dans
son prochain
on est tendu oui je sais mais aussi
voudront pas le travail non non non pas
répondants elle va elle regardait là
elle a peur
elle apparaît la vie ma gueule c'est
magnifique désolé je dépannais se
déprécie pas varié on écrit on était sur
les tromperies parce que c'est vrai que
sylvie non dans le film tu te fais
trompé qui a pardonné une personne alors
qu'elle vous avez trompé qui a déjà
pardonné
il faut pardonner à chaque fois ma
partie pour la personne ne le dit ainsi
je le découvre c'est autre chose mais à
angers relie les gens comme ils savent
que je moi je pardonne je n'ai pas envie
de tout briser si c'est une belle
histoire pour les histoires calif
voilà donc je pardonne assez facilement
c'est une femme qui trompe peut être
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
khedira dont on avait dans le sens où
c'est une femme qui trompe sache que la
femme a pas trompés juste pour le 500
écoutes étaient venus avec le moral
c'est pas comme on le sait c'est aussi
dans le cerveau j'adore ce qu'est ce que
des cas la raison
quand une femme trompe son tir a lyon
c'est parce qu'on aurait général ça veut
dire que l'histoire est finie alors
qu'un compagnon peut mettre des coups de
couteau dans des biens ce même à
l'embrasser elle va l'embrasser avaler
clarifier ça va mais trouve sa famille
il la presse pas il la caresse pas
spécialement c'est vrai ça super content
vraiment qu'on continue de tomber ces
chiffres donnent michael suivi bon
évidemment il faut aimer c'est pardonné
et mes bagages et on m'a trompé ça peut
arriver ça peut arriver
en tout cas c'est au tour des mini qu'on
a envie que ça continue il faut savoir
pardonner à fait ma foi va leur faire
confiance
pas forcément une sorte d'arrêt qui
pardonnerait alors tu as l'air hyper
amoureuse vous vous pardonnez pas
bénigne
j'aurais du mal d'acteurs et du mal sur
le papier intellectuellement je peux me
dire que mon histoire vaut le coup et
que je peux essayer le problème c'est
qu'on a toujours un petit coin dans la
tête ou 11 on y repense et redonner une
confiance c'est compliqué kelly jamais
jamais de lalo mais ça revient tout le
temps de façon même une four on peut
essayer faire un déni de la chose mais
ça revient pas mal et après vous dire
désagréable même si ça va on a compris
même dix fois tout le temps franchement
vous aimiez ou non mais jamais comme
kelly c'est le ver dans la pomme mais je
suis inquiet la raison je pardonne pas
mais moi non plus au moins deux fois et
que vous avez envie qu on vous pardonne
si un jour ça vous arrive
ah non je vais franchement alors moi
déjà ça m'arriverait déjà seront alors
oui donc finalement renvoyé l'invité
mystère pour
[Rires]
non pas parce que moi je ne pardonnerai
pas je ne pardonnerai pas je vous dis
voilà je vous le dis je pardonnerai pas
marqué ce que tu as roma non mais si
mais si tu cherches dans telle fille je
suis là tu cherches
est ce que pour vous embrasser s'est
trompé oui pierre entre deux portes
entre deux portes tant d'éloges à
boulogne ce qu'il a fait j'ai vu dans la
logique isabelle ça serait beau utiliser
mika est ce que j'adore lui chantal la
grille kalevala franchement oui j'aime
beaucoup votre pièce
[Applaudissements]
isabelle est ce que vous êtes attiré par
michael un petit bisou vite fait arrêter
ça numérique oui je suis gêné un contenu
ans de grève de graphite
merci merci nous est pas moi merci à 10
mois isabelle oui tu as une décision à
prendre
est ce que tu as envie de moi s'il
n'avait pas du tout mais ça m'a jamais
emballé à la salive tout ça en mai
célébration d'un coup là j'ai pu je suis
pas je suis plus haut jamais su bloquer
mais oui le coeur y est malade il avait
choqué c'est toi tu chauffes très vite
et urbain son nom mais ça y est un des
congélateurs
ouais d'un glaçon week voileux tromperie
je veux je lui connais bien bas alors on
va chercher là on va chercher à
l'annuaire benjamin castaldi avec une
tromperie qui étaient reliés par les par
les journaux c'est très pénible
ah ouais ouais quoi que convoitent ouais
la troisième place est 2e en partant de
la gauche totalement rigaud leurs
antennes et benjamin me disais je
donnerai pas le montant il me disait
cool ça lui coûte tout ça a tout fait
dix morts son iphone à sienne 1-2 quand
toutes les semaines vous avez la
couverture avec avec l'autre mec et tous
les détails
c'est très pénible après d'euros
[Applaudissements]